Am I even here?
Do you...
Am I here?
Hello?
Are we okay?
Wait, why?
Oh, there it is.
Hmm?
What do I do?
Oh no!
No!
What do I do?
Oh my gosh.
Oh god, oh
god.
Am I here?
if i can be on the screen i don't know if i can be on the
screen i think it might be too much for for everything i
can't even reach out
i'm here i don't think i can do it be on the screen maybe oh
my gosh And I can't, I can only reach out through OBS.
I think I broke YouTube.
I'm a Kiriyuki.
Hey guys, Merry Christmas.
I can't tell if you...
Oh, the chat, I think, came back.
I can't tell.
Can you guys hear me?
Or...
See me?
Oh, my God.
We can hear you.
Okay, guys.
I don't know if this is going to happen.
I'm sorry.
oh
i'm so sorry
i am still not home so i will do stream tomorrow too when i
am home
youtube grieving the ghost i don't i don't think it's like i
think it's either tube or something because from the hotel
just the other day so i'm why now it's acting like a little
baby i can't i can't i'm sorry wait maybe i can go on hot
spot i'm gonna switch the hot spot One moment.
One moment.
I forgot.
Wait, why am I not moving anymore?
What's happening?
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Am I here?
Am I back?
Is it...
Is it very...
grainy.
Am I, do I look okay at least?
It's a crisp, it's a miracle.
Bit rate is bad.
Hold on, let me see if I can.
It's crispy.
Crispy.
It is more stable now.
That was the Wi-Fi.
That was the which is crazy it's so crazy because in my last
hotel room which was in the same hotel but that's so weird
that's so weird
ohio shoe shushi no mediculi hi ohio hi dad i don't know if
you guys can tell but my voice is like so not good right now
I...
Okay, wait, can we start over?
Can I go back to the opening screen and start?
Gosh, this is so cursed.
I'm sorry, everybody.
Okay, take two, take two.
Stop it!
Oh, do my voice.
Oh, my voice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hello, everybody!
Oh,
my voice might be a little bad.
What is my bit rate usually, I wonder?
I can't remember.
I wonder if I can increase it.
Let me see.
Maybe that'll be better.
I'm not sick or anything.
thing i just uh really i really no my voice is dead you guys
not dad um i i used my voice this past weekend was uh was
was holiday maturi and i had so many recording things that i
needed to do and whatever you say you dead i'm dad
my contribution to the bill i'll be okay i'll be okay thank
you boss for your humble sacrifice for us i've always of
course oh i'm your father today and i'm i'm i'm gonna sing
you some christmas carols where's the oh oh did you guys
hear that sorry i dropped my oh my gosh
i'm gonna sing you some christmas carols we're gonna we're
gonna have a good time pipe start wow what
was that that was me dropping my headphones because i can't
put them in my ears because the music is too loud because if
i control the sound on my goxlr then you guys can't hear it
so i have to like hold them up slightly to
that this is the most scuffed scuffed oh but we're gonna
sing you guys um as you can tell i don't sound so great
because i had a convention this past weekend where i get too
excited and i yell at people because i get excited to see
them again i'm like except much cuter hopefully
so i'm gonna do a little bit of karaoke because I promised,
I promised, I promised that I would do Christmas karaoke.
And you guys, I can't believe it's Christmas Eve.
It's Christmas Eve.
Sumi!
Hi, Dad, it's my birthday.
Could I get a super quick happy Christmas?
Happy birthday song, please.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Sumi.
day to you.
You're supposed to rest your voice when you strain and not
do karaoke, but I promise.
I don't want to be a liar.
So it's just a little bit.
It's just a little bit.
I have tea and cough drop.
It wouldn't be Christmas karaoke.
if i did it after christmas though
i have to do it for christmas cheers to the anniversary of
you getting me and my another abu did you guys know we
changed the name from wisp to ibu if you like the name wisp
you can keep using it but i will use ibu from now on i
decided i don't care i don't care
I got sick and missed my best friend's birthday.
Could you help me?
Well, redeem me with a short happy birthday, though.
Kodiak house husband.
boy's day.
We are eyeball.
You are my eyeball and my eyeball.
Yeah.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
Hope you enjoyed home.
I get lots of rest.
I dyed my hair mint green and cosplayed you for our...
I wish I could have seen!
Did I take pictures?
Merry Christmas!
Should we sing you guys?
Let's get a song out of the way.
I'm gonna do a bit of a...
What do you call?
Hey!
Soundcheck.
With the song.
So let's soundcheck what...
Sorry I have no BGM playing.
It's really just a...
It's scuffed.
I have no music.
just my thoughts and my feelings and you guys so let's try
thank you for singing but don't stress yourself out this is
all for fun it's all for fun you guys no no worries no no
worries at all oh I wanted to change my hair hold on I had
twin tails earlier one second one second
Oh, you saw nothing.
I got it.
There we go.
Twin tails.
Sorry if I'm still crunchy.
I will send some pictures if anybody wanted to get some
picture of my...
my Christmas outfit.
Looking a thousand percent better.
It looks okay.
Oh, good.
Good, good.
Yippee.
Okay, let's see.
What should I sing first, you guys?
What's a good warm-up song?
Feliz Navidam.
Let's do that one.
That's a good one.
Feliz Navidam.
Okay.
I hear I hold it up close to my ear.
Tell me if it's too loud.
I can't hear it.
Belize Navidad.
What the?
It's good.
Thank you.
Belize Navidad.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my
heart
Feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad Prospero Año and
Felizidad Felizas Navidad Dad Dad
Dad I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a
Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas From the
bottom I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a
Merry Christmas From the bottom of my heart Dad Dad
Dad Dad Dad Dad I
wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry
Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas From the bottom
of my heart I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish
you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas
I was one of the cosplayers with the homer eyes.
It was so cute.
You were so cute.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I got the thumbnail recommended after a clip and I said you
started Seven hours ago, but Kamiyoshi is so darn cute.
Also, um, uh, once, wait, I, there was a, there was a
donald, but my thing is broken.
My stream labs is broken.
Let me, hold on, let me see if I can read it.
Don't worry, I'm not sick.
Just overworked.
I don't know if that's any better.
yeah I also was lazy and I didn't do my double wait what do
you mean verify it's me oh my gosh okay
uh verify
my oh she is dead you can always say no no that one always
is yours I want it to be I don't know I wish I could have
signed it or something so cute imposter Monday was my
birthday.
Happy birthday, Ricka Tan!
Happy birthday!
Sorry, I missed it.
So sorry.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I've been kind of all over the place.
I, um, also, Fisnab, thank you so much for the, for the,
Akadu, Akasupa, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um, I went to, I went to, uh, so I had, at the Sunday collab
with with Mimi, Barry and Ashton.
And then the day after we all went to, we all went to Disney
together.
And then the day after that, I was like, I don't think I've
had enough theme park.
So it was like, it was like afternoon.
I was like, I think I'm gonna go to SeaWorld.
And so I went to SeaWorld.
And then I was like, you know, I think, I think I might want
to, um, also, um, want to go to theme park today.
Uh, I almost went to epic.
Did you see the orcas?
No, my gosh, orca.
There were so many signs that were like this way to the orca
zone.
And I was like, oh my gosh, it's just going to be full of
Yuri.
I was thinking of you the whole time, my wife.
But man, are my arms tired?
No, SeaWorld was so funny.
I went, I remember, okay.
There was one ride at SeaWorld that I thought was out of
operation now.
It's called Journey to Atlantis.
And I went on it once as a wee wisp.
And I remember it was, so I was too small to...
ride Kraken right and so I was like well this is the only
thrilling ride that I can ride here so it was like my
favorite thing journey to Atlantis and I remember like you
would go in and there would be like the projection of the
face on the mermaid and they're like you must set me free
I've been turned to stone by Medusa and then there was like
a little seahorse guy that was like and and she's like you
will never leave and i i was like oh my gosh i can't wait to
relive all of this and i get on this ride guys everything
was broken the story was removed yes the story was removed
and everything was broken i was so sad medusa lit up but she
was supposed to like lean towards do and be all spooky i was
so it was so disappointing and then also to like fulfill my
inner my inner baby wisp i went on kraken because i was like
finally i could do it no it was okay it was okay the park
itself was great but um yeah it's definitely uh
sea world has kind of fallen off recently even over here in
california it wasn't so it wasn't
it wasn't so good but there was one thing um uh someone
mentioned the flying dinosaur at universal there was a ride
there's a peter peter sorry a peter dactyl ride i usj
universal studios japan that i really wanted to ride that i
was like oh But it was so cold that I, like the whole group
I was with, we were like, we were like, no, it's too cold
for this, I think.
And so we skipped it.
And I was like, I'm kind of regretting it.
And I brought this up.
And someone that I know that works on roller coasters and
stuff is like, oh, if you go to SeaWorld, there's one that's
exactly like it.
And so I was just like, I was like, oh, I'll go ride that.
And it's called Manta.
It was really good.
That mantle was so, so good.
It was really crazy.
It really felt like you were...
I don't know if it's a similar track to the pterodactyl one.
But...
Oh my gosh, Capo!
It's super...
Thank you.
Roller coaster cloning is pretty common.
Yeah, exactly.
So I figured now that I've written that, I know the
pterodactyl one pretty well.
It was so fun.
Merry Christmas, boss, and all the I booze tonight.
Yeah, I'll put your karaoke on my TV while my family enjoys
hot pot and blue label expensive whiskey.
Ooh, fancy.
Uh-oh, I should sing then some more, huh?
Manta is insane.
It was so fun because, like, you, when you do the loop,
like, you are pushed back.
So basically the ride, um, to give anybody who doesn't know
it, um, you are sitting in the seat and then the seat goes
back.
So you're, you're facing the ground.
your face is facing the ground and you're like kind of you
know really trusting that harness there i was like oh my
gosh it would be so inconvenient if my if the person i
possessed fell out and died and i would have to find another
body to possess you know um because this body doesn't throw
up over on roller coasters so it's kind of like annoying to
have to find another body but anyway yeah it's really
inconvenient so
So, yeah, you're like facing the ground and you're looking
at it and you're like, wow, this is so scary.
But there's a loop in it.
And when the loop happens, you're like pushed back to the
back of your seat.
And it's like, it's such a crazy, weird floaty, floaty,
floaty feeling.
So, you can borrow mine.
Okay.
What's another song I should sing?
What's another song?
Sad after Christmas.
No, don't be sad.
Don't be sad.
I'll sing Happy Santa.
Christmas songs only, everybody.
Last Christmas?
Like, that's kind of like a sad song, though, no?
I'll try it.
You're a Bukami Tai covered.
Oh, I typed all the wrong thing.
Last Christmas.
Christmas song only, everybody.
Sorry, I don't know any Hanukkah songs.
I guess holiday songs only, but I think I only know
Christmas.
I'm sorry.
Let's try this one.
There's words here.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart, but the
best this year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to
someone special.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart But the
very...
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone
special
Once bitten and twice shy I keep my distance, but you still
catch my eye Tell me, baby, do you recognize?
me well it's been a year it doesn't surprise me happy
Christmas I wrapped it up and sent it with a note saying I
love you I meant it now I know what a fool I've been but if
you kissed me now I know you'd fool me again last Christmas
I gave you my heart but the very next day you gave Give it
away This year To save me from tears I'll give it to someone
special Last Christmas I gave you my heart But the very next
day You give it away This year To save me from tears I'll
give it to someone special
Oh, my baby.
The voice is dotting, huh?
I'm hiding from you and your soul of ice.
My God, I thought you were someone to rely on me.
I guess I was a shoulder to cry on.
Face on a lover with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, what you tore at me apart.
Ooh, now I've found a real love, you'll never fool me again.
Last Christmas, I gave you my heart, hey, you gave it away.
This year, to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone
special.
Christmas I gave you my heart You gave me away
I'll give it to someone special Special Oh, special Oh, gave
you my heart How long is it holding this note for?
I'll give it to someone I'll give it to someone This is
someone special Special
Someone one one
Yippee Someone one one one Thank you for being you, Minty
You're welcome.
I don't know how else to be I don't know.
I can't be anybody else I think let's see no reverb i don't
think this thing has reverb sorry i don't think it has
reverb i'm just i'm raw dog in it love that thank you what's
another hmm i'm gonna just search christmas wait i wonder if
there's like a
christmas here we go
Let's try this one.
This one is kind of funny.
White Christmas.
Oh, gosh.
Can my voice even do that one?
The Christmas song.
What is that one?
Hold on.
Let me hear it.
I gotta hear it real quick.
I'm listening.
Just nuts roasting on an open fire.
Oh, my gosh.
My voice.
Jack Frost sniffing at your nose Euletide carols being sung
by a choir And folks dressed up like Eskimos Everybody knows
A turkey and some mistletoe
Season bright Tiny tauts with their eyes all aglow Taylor
tauts will find it hard to sleep tonight They know that
Santa's on his way He's loaded lots of toys and goodies on
his sleigh And every mother's child is gonna spy To see if
reindeer really know how to fly And so I'm offering this
simple phrase To kids from 1 to 92 Cannibalism although it's
been said many times many ways merry christmas to you
oh gosh sorry i thought i muted thank you so much for that
good so much thank you i'm drinking water don't worry guys
water break yeah and so i'm offering This simple phrase To
kids from 1 to 9 to 2 Though it's been said many times, many
ways Merry Christmas, okay, never mind To you
Let's go.
I just also realized I don't have like a set up.
I don't have, or not set up, sorry, a set list up.
So anybody, any of the lovely Aibur who are time stamping?
I'll leave it to you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for being your man.
Merry Christmas.
Let's do a fun one.
Which is not where I'm staying on an open fire.
I can't sing it like him.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell rock.
Jingle bells swing and jingle bells ring.
Snowing and blowing up bushels of fun.
Now the jingle hop has begun.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell.
rock jingle bells chime in jingle bell time dancing and
prancing in jingle bell square in the frosty air what a
bright time it's the right time to rock the hook jingle bell
time is a swell time to go gliding in a one-horse sleigh
Jingle horse, pick up your feet.
Jingle around the clock.
Mix and mingle in the jingling beat.
What are these words?
They don't even make sense.
Hold on, I'm going to get a cough drop.
Let the chorus sing.
Oh, yeah.
Jingle bell chime and jingle bell chime.
Dancing and francing in jingle bell square.
In the frosty air.
The bright top means the right drop.
One horse and a kitty up, jingle horse, pick up your feet.
I can't hear the music at all.
Jingle the road, the clock.
Mix and don't mingle in the jingling feet.
That's the jingle bell.
That's the jingle bell rock.
I apologize in advance if everybody's waiting for Santa baby
and it sounds kind of...
You know what I mean?
Okay, the next song.
Let's try this one.
And everyone's like, I'm ready to get pregnant!
I don't know if it'll happen.
I
don't know, whatever.
This is all for fun.
But I do apologize that I'm not in my best, uh, my best, um,
condition.
Yeah.
Minky toughening it out for the peeps.
Thank you guys so much for all the returning memberships and
blue Christmas.
Oh, that's a good one.
Thank you.
Just wanted to comment.
Thank you so much for the super chat as well.
Thank you for all the don't knows and super chats and
everything.
Stop apologizing.
I can't help it.
Where is Mr. Elvis?
Mr. Presley?
Oh, wait.
Wait, no, that's here.
Come Santa Claus.
Where is he?
Oh, no, that's, that's, this is not a popular song.
Hold on, let me find it.
Blue Christmas.
Oh, so can you guys hear my name?
laptop being like super loud
just had my surgery i'll have a blue christmas without you
i'll be so blue just thinking how about you
will not be the same here if you're not here with me i win
those blue snowflakes star falling let's win those blue
memories star calling
My Freddy Fazbear.
Right when they are Christmas of white.
But I'll have a boo, boo, boo Christmas.
Chestnuts roasting on.
Or...
Brogbert cover.
start to finish it off strong
i don't even know if i can do frog burp right now your
christmas
oh boy did i know who elvis is of a blue blue blue blue blue
christmas sorry
you guys
let's do this one okay for this next song i'm gonna need you
guys to sing the guy part okay and i'll sing the girl who is
trying to run away from you all right
okay copy that all right
I really can't But baby, it's cold outside I've got to go
away But baby, it's cold outside This evening has been So
very nice I'll hold your hand They're just like I A mother
will start to Beautiful, what's your hurry?
A father will be pacing the floor Listen to the fireplace So
really, I'd better stay Maybe just to have a drink more The
paper's my thing Say what's in this drink?
No caps to be had out there I wish I knew how To break the
spell I'll take your hat Your hair looks swirled No, no, no,
no Mind if I'm moving closer At least I'm gonna say that I
tried I really can't stay Baby, it's cold outside thank you
I've been practicing I simply must go the answer is no oh
baby it's cold outside welcome how lucky that you dropped in
oh nice and warm look out the window at the storm gosh your
lips look delicious waves upon a tropical shore you don't
have to say it again never such a blessing before baby
you'll freeze out there it's up to your knees out there it's
a really big friend but don't you see how can you do this
thing to me it's bound to be a talk to mom at least they
will be playing If you're caught pneumonia and bad.
I really can't say.
Get over that holdout.
Baby it's cold outside.
Oh, it's cold outside.
Why do you say it twice?
Gosh, your lips look delicious.
We going to jail on Christmas with this one, boys.
Let's go.
false imprisonment.
Can you even see my lips?
I'm going to get rid of this.
Oh, we can't now.
It's kind of shiny.
I put, um, I put some lip gloss on.
Okay.
lucky give me that here wait wait let me just scoot over a
little bit
is my scarf even on right i think it's fine sorry if it's a
little scuff scroll wheel you can do it yeah sorry you can
hear it off it's amazing seeing you on the main cafe thank
you is my birthday gift for my significant other cosplay do
all weekend and she won the raffle play sugar owens
um let's see what's another song
what's that one song that i'll be home for christmas
christmas you're a mean one that's one That one's fun too.
Can we rename the holiday Mintmus?
Wait, oh yes, you guys are so right.
Happy birthday, Otaru!
Happy birthday, happy birthday.
Coolies, moist.
Let's do the psychopath song.
You guys are saying so many, but don't worry, we'll get too
many of them.
Yeah.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer Walking home from our
house Christmas Eve You can say there's no such thing as
Santa But as with me and Grandpa, we believe She'd been
drinking too much eggnog And we begged her not to go
medication and she staggered out the door into the snow when
we found her Christmas morning at the scene of the attack my
gosh she had hoof prints on her forehead and incriminating
claw marks on her back oh my god grandma got run over by a
reindeer walking home from a Christmas Eve.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
I don't think they have claw marks.
We're all proud of Grandpa.
Why?
He's been taking this so well.
See him in there watching football, drinking beer and
playing cards with Cousin Mel.
It's not Christmas without grandma.
All the families trust in black.
And we just can't help but wonder, should we open up her
gifts or send them back?
Look at why does the crowd say send them back.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
And as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
Outsu, arigato, now the goose is on the table.
And the pudding made.
And the blue and silver candles.
That would have matched the hair in Grandma's wig.
I've warned all my friends and neighbors.
You better watch out for yourselves.
somewhere.
We don't know when he will strike next.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
Now you can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and grandpa we believe.
Sing it grandpa.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Oh, this thing is sent up.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
Murphy sent one of his extra meito plushies, and this is
where he wants me to send the payment for the shipping.
Merry Christmas, Vito.
Oh, Moe-fi.
Moe-fi.
Are you out there, Vivian?
there being are you out there being santa my birthday was
last week nantua happy birthday and i'm so glad i'm so glad
night sky patrols you were able to get a posse
would you guys want me to re-release them i know that the
last batch took quite a long time to to to ship out so i
felt really bad um
um doing another small plush design uh still waiting on the
fumo oh yeah yeah that will take a that will take a bit um
that that would still don't worry actually actually i think
it's soon though i think it's soon
celebrating christmas minkie good night minto good night I
will be left out cookies and milk for Santa.
I can't help me.
Some of us are a bit new.
I will see what I can do.
Yeah, if you rearrange the letters in Santa, you get Mito.
What's your cookie preference?
Um...
Hmm.
You need a second one for Oshikatsu?
Todd, ain't she extra lovely today?
You think it's a new lipstick?
What are you talking about?
Some people want a second.
So maybe I should try and do the other design then.
Is that what you're saying?
Okay, okay, mmm, mmm, mmm.
I made snicker cookies and gave them to...
gave them out Merry Xmas.
Merry Xmas!
Snicker cookie sounds amazing.
I love snicker doodles!
Ducky!
Sorry you had to see me a bunch.
Shut up, dummy.
Of course I like seeing you.
And talking with Oshi makes you happy.
I'm trying to make more animations.
No, and none of you are so busy.
Actually, I think my favorite type of cookie is an oatmeal
cookie.
Am I the only one?
Don't do the karaoke.
Oh, Driddle, Driddle, Driddle.
I'm me too out of clay.
And when it's dry, I'm ready.
With Driddle, I shall play.
Yeah.
With or without raisins.
Oh.
I'm fine with either.
Actually, I really love raisins.
I really like raisins, though.
I don't eat oatmeal cookies.
O'Meal's a solid choice.
I'm glad that my chat is so...
You guys are so great.
The eyeball or the bust.
Leave out cookies and milk and John Snake Metal Gear for
you.
Thank you!
Watch the frog look.
I'm doing membership.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What else can we sing?
No, what about this one?
Do I know this one?
I might have just picked it.
Oh, I'll do the Grinch after this one.
Oh, just kidding.
It switched over to the Grinch.
I thought I added it to my queue.
Okay, I'll do the other one.
You're a mean one, Mr. Grinch.
You really are a heel.
You're as cuddly as a cactus.
charming as an eel, Mr. Grinch.
You're a bad banana with a greasy black peel.
Ah, well, thank you!
You're a monster, Mr. Grinch.
Your heart's an empty hole.
Your brain is full of spiders and you've got Garlic in your
soul.
Mmm, Mr. Grinch.
I wouldn't touch you with what?
39 and a half foot pole.
You're a vile one.
Mr. Grinch.
You loved her.
My sin.
Your smile.
You have all the tender sweetness of a seasick crocodile.
Mr. Grinch.
Wait.
I'll give you the choice between the two of you.
I'll take the seasick crocodile.
You're a silly one, Miss Minky.
You're a router, Mr. Grinch.
You're the king of sinful thoughts.
Your heart's a dead purple spot.
Mr. Grinch!
You're a three-decker sourcrown toadstool sandwich with
arsenic sauce!
You nauseate me.
Mr. Grinch.
With a nausea, super nice!
You're a crooked, jerky, jocky, and you drive a crooked
horse.
Mr. Grinch!
Your soul is an appalling dumb peep overflowing with the
most disgraceful assortment of rubbish imaginable, mingled
up in, I can't speak.
You're a foul one, Mr. Grinch.
You're a nasty, wastey skunk.
Your heart is full of unwashed socks.
is full of gunk mr grinch the three words that best describe
you are as follows and i quote stink stank stank
i'm a poor guy i love the grinch though is this the one that
i was going to sing before?
I can't remember now.
I think so, yeah.
Very cute one.
My domain.
Have yourself a merry little Christmas.
Sorry, I thought it was very...
Let your heart be light.
From now on... Wait, what is the key?
here i can't tell at all oh i need help help me have
yourself a merry little christmas make the yule tide game
from now on our troubles will be miles
Here we are as in olden
days of your war.
Faithful friends who are dear to us, gather near to us once
more.
We all will be together If the fates allow
Hang a shining star Upon the highest bow Oh gosh, sorry And
have yourself A merry little Christmas Now
gather near to us once more Through the years we all will be
together I try nothing to hide Allow So hang a shining star
upon the Highest bow
And of yourself A merry little Christmas
No big beef, thank you My cough drop really did its job well
Let's see, what else we got here
but you're the fool no i'm sorry that it's so not good in my
voice right now
i'm gonna i could sing ariana grande Santa baby there you
really care that is my birthday tomorrow razor happy
birthday happy happy birthday hmm we could do this one
because Santa comes tomorrow or tonight.
Does he come starting midnight?
What do you think he starts?
Oh my gosh, I love the Santa like tracker that they put on.
It's like, where is Santa right now?
We are stalking him across the globe.
You know that thing.
Die hard Christmas movie or not?
Yes.
You better not cry.
You better not pout.
I'm telling you why.
Yeah, Nora!
He's making a list and checking it twice He's gonna find out
who's naughty or nice Santa Claus is coming to town He sees
you when you're sleeping He knows when you're away He knows
if you've been bad good soul be good for goodness sake you
better watch out you better not cry you better not cry you
better not cry cuz Santa Claus is coming to town oh let's go
by the way guys next next stream I have an announcement from
a positive good So, um...
Uh, stream will
I- He sees you when you're sleeping He knows when you're
awake He knows if you've been bad or good So be good for
goodness Goodness, in this sake
You better watch out You better not cry You better not pout,
I'm telling you why Santa Claus is coming to town Thanks for
the announcement of the announcement You better watch out,
you better not cry You better know about, I'm telling you
why Santa Claus is coming I need that big fat man, wait He's
coming to town Down!
Yippee!
Let me drink some more water.
Oh.
Two good news, Merry Christmas.
Milk.
Thank you so much for that.
I got so much.
Thank you.
Okay, my voice was not hurting before.
Now it's starting to hurt.
so i think i'll do just two more songs
just two more songs i think let me drink some more water
Rudolph we'll do Rudolph and then we'll end with Santa baby
does that sound good everybody i'm sorry it's a bit shorter
i want to talk about everything that i've been doing but i
also don't want to talk so much TV table trade.
Thank you.
And watch the frog.
Thank you for the gifted membership.
Thank you.
Please don't overdo it.
I think maybe I will take off for Christmas and then Koise
Moise.
So I'll have a day off to rest.
And then we'll resume our regularly scheduled programming
the day after Christmas.
Does that sound good?
Hmm.
So...
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Cool.
Let's sing...
I'll save Santa Baby last, obviously.
Rudolph.
This is a cute one.
So sorry, that's a shorter stream, though.
I'm sorry!
You know, Dasher and Dancer and Prancer and Vixen Comet and
Cupid and Darn and listen but do you recall the most famous
reindeer of all Rudolph the red nose reindeer had a very
shiny nose and if you ever saw it you would even say it goes
all of the other reindeer used to laugh and call in the
night Pinocchio.
They never left poor Rudolph.
Joining any reindeer games like Monopoly.
Then one foggy Christmas Eve, Santa came to say, oh, oh, oh.
Rudolph with your nose so bright.
Won't you guide my sleigh tonight?
Then how the reindeer loved him.
As they shouted out with glee, yuppie.
Rudolph the deer you'll go down in history
oh wow this is a long break wait i'm gonna need to make it
smaller for it's a red doodle
doodle after red nose reindeer had a very shiny nose and if
you ever saw it.
You would even say it glows.
All of the other reindeer used to laugh and call it names.
They never let poor Rudolph join another reindeer game.
Then when foggy Christmas Eve Santa came to say, Oh, oh, oh,
Rudolph with your nose so bright, She'll guide my sleigh
tonight Then how the reindeer loved him As they shouted out
quickly Yippee Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer You'll go down
in history Oh That was so fast I'm spending Christmas all by
myself this year Work reasons so thank you for streaming
today Of course Tuxedo Cat Of course You're never alone
We're all together We're all together.
Merry Christmas, Mito.
Merry Christmas, Joshua!
Thank you guys for being so patient with me.
Yeah, I really appreciate it.
Nina!
Thank you for making Christmas extra cozy.
I love you!
I'm saving your baka mitai for tomorrow as a Christmas
present for myself, but I'm very stoked about the collab.
Have a great Christmas, Yuto!
Oh my gosh.
I think...
Did you guys hear the baka mitai?
If you haven't heard it yet, I posted it.
I posted it in like the notes, so you can read it there or
listen to it there.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for talking, Silva.
Thank you.
Being able to spend time with you is the best Christmas
present, disciple, good ask for.
You guys are gonna make me cry.
Yeah.
No.
Oh my gosh, Silva Gunner.
What the heck?
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me.
Crazy.
Can't control.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many, so many, so many, so many times.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Nashi!
Hope you have a lovely mintimus.
Now take care of my voice.
I'm glad I was able to record everything in time.
Sorry.
And before.
Grandad.
Oh my gosh.
Merry Christmas Thank you so much Thank you so much Thank
you Oh thank you guys for being so patient with me Luckily
After Once I'm back home tomorrow Streams will be Regular
again So I have no plans To leave Anytime Like for any more
travel Anytime soon at least So at least for all of January
until February but the February thing will be also part of
the announcement so a little bit and I'm very excited too oh
gosh I just want to stream so badly I just want to stream so
badly you'll get those 50 games yeah I have to get the 50
games still Actually, Sunday I intended on streaming again,
but it turned into the collab, so...
Are you guys ready for the final song?
The song everybody's been waiting for?
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Pause?
Pause.
There we go.
Oh, I'll start it over.
When I go.
Tiny Christmas gift on mint.
Merry Christmas.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh, I forgot my nose.
You're right.
Oh my gosh.
Sketch.
Thank you.
I don't think I should have this on for this.
Merry mint mess and thanks for streaming.
I'm homesick so my nose is red too.
Keep it on.
Oh, keep the nose.
oops whatever happened to the cardboard dress it's still
around but that's not it's that's not what i'm wearing today
that was my jazzy dress keep the nose okay hold on you guys
are so nose you guys are so demanding you're like the nose
stays on minky the nose stays on
Docky docky Dead nose Are you guys ready?
I'll do my best Hold on Let me take some more water
Last song, Santa baby Here we go
Santa baby
Just slip a sable under the tree for me Been an awful good
girl, Santa baby So hurry down the chimney tonight
Santa baby, a 54 convertible to light blue I'll wait up for
you dear baby so hurry down the chimney tonight
think of all the fun i've missed think of all the i boo that
i haven't kissed next year i could be just as good if you
check off my christmas list Santa baby I want a yacht and
really that's not a lie Been an angel all year Santa baby so
hurry down the chimney tonight
Aibu honey One little thing I really need the dear To a
platinum mine, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney
tonight.
Santa cutie.
Fill my stocking with a duplex and checks.
Sign your X on the line, Santa cutie.
And hurry down the chimney tonight.
Come and trim my Christmas tree With some decorations bought
at Tiffany's I really do believe in you Let's see if you
believe in me Santa baby, I forgot to mention one little
thing A ring I don't meet on the floor Santa baby So hurry
down the chimney tonight Hurry down the chimney tonight
Hurry Tonight
Yeah.
Yay.
I want to wish you guys such a Merry Christmas.
And, and, you know, I hope that you guys have, you know,
whether you're with family or friends or anyone, or if
you're just coming to hang out with us, I hope you and if
you don't celebrate Christmas, I hope whatever holiday you
do celebrate this season has been just as just as awesome.
And, you know, you guys, you guys are always just the best.
So thank you.
I think you've already given me a present with that song.
Nixie.
Thank you for the Christmas, Oki.
I will see if I can stream tomorrow.
If not, then I will see you guys when I stream next.
But Nick, thank you so much.
Thank you, Minto, for bearing with hotel Wi-Fi and dad
voice, of course.
Second ever hug.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas, happy holidays, man.
Thank you, Jumpey.
Thank you, thank you.
Anthony, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, everybody.
Merry Minky Miss.
Hopefully next time you hear me, my voice is a little bit
more recovered.
So, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I will rest my voice.
This is, yes.
Sorry for my dad voice.
.
Dad, .
Dad .
Thank you, everybody.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, I can't keep going.
I can't keep talking anymore.
Okay.
Oh, it's Minto!
Oh, I forgot to welcome you guys in.
Well, but unfortunately, I must kick you all out.
I love you guys.
Have a wonderful Christmas time, holiday time.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.